Look, not every movie is going to have you
on the edge of your seat.
After all, they can't all be Con Air.
"Put the bunny back in the box."
Still, you'd think that if anyone's going
to stay awake through a whole movie, it's
the actors who star in them.
But that's not always how it plays out.
Whether out of boredom or sheer exhaustion,
here are a few movie stars who've copped to
dozing off during their own movies.
Michael Shannon
There are few actors working today who are
as outspoken as Michael Shannon.
Whether he's going on a political rant or
trash-talking the entire movie industry, Shannon
doesn't hesitate to say exactly how he feels.
In the role of Zod, Shannon had one of the
most crucial parts in Batman v. Superman:
Dawn of Justice.
And that's saying a lot, since his character
was pretty much dead part of the time.
But don't ask Shannon how the rest of the
film turned out, because he slept through
the thing.
Shannon told Fandango that the first time
he tried to watch the film, he got punched
by the Sandman: "I watched it once and I fell
asleep ... I was on an international flight
and I was tired."
Johnny Depp
In 2015, Depp earned plenty of praise for
his performance as legendary Boston crime
boss Whitey Bulger in Black Mass.
The drama went on to gross a respectable $62
million at the box office, which occurred
shortly after its high-profile screening at
the Venice International Film Festival.
Depp was in attendance for that — or at
least his physical form was.
He later confessed on Jimmy Kimmel Live that
he didn't make it all the way through the
movie.
"And fell asleep in the movie?
I fell asleep about 15 times.
I remember my wife was kinda..
Empf!
Empf!"
It's not that he didn't like the movie.
It's just that, as he explained, he has, quote,
"a problem watching films of any kind, unless
it's a documentary."
One of the highest-paid actors alive hates
watching movies.
Huh.
Brenton Thwaites
Jeff Bridges tried to bring Lois Lowry's young
adult dystopian classic The Giver to the big
screen for more than two decades.
And when he began the process in the mid-nineties,
he envisioned his father, Lloyd Bridges, in
the title role.
By the time the movie came out in 2014, though,
Jeff Bridges himself was old enough to play
the Giver.
The role of Jonas, the Young Person Who Will
Save the World, went to Australian actor Brenton
Thwaites.
Despite the career-making potential of the
part, Thwaites actually dozed off the first
time he watched The Giver.
He told Nova 106.9: "They set up a screening
with me and Jeff [Bridges].
I was so tired that I kept falling asleep,
during my own movie."
Shia LaBeouf
Performance art stunts have kind of become
Shia LaBeouf's thing in recent years.
Not too long ago, he decided to live alone
in a cabin in Finland for a month, just because
he's Shia LaBeouf.
"Living in the woods.
Shia Lebeouf."
"Living for sport.
"Eating all the bodies."
"Actual cannibal, Shia Lebeouf."
So back in December 2015, Shia LaBeouf famously
held a film festival in his own honor at the
Angelika Film Center in New York.
Titled, conveniently, #ALLMYMOVIES, the film
festival involved LaBeouf sitting in a movie
theater and watching every movie he's ever
starred in, in reverse chronological order.
That's about three day's worth of films, so
it's understandable that LaBeouf fell asleep
at some point.
When he did finally doze off, it was to Transformers:
Dark of the Moon.
And he wasn't alone.
Describing the event, he later said:
"[During] Transformers 2 they could feel when
I sunk in my seat.
That’s not a performative thing.
That’s me going through some kind of crisis.
And I’m not the only one.
I remember right before I fell asleep I looked
next to me and the guy next to me was falling
asleep.
You can see it on the screenshot we’re both
And the guy behind us is asleep."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!